the importance of properly
choosing one's words when you
speak or even when you think
When you think to self. That is
the basis of speech. Speech is
merely a physical way of
articulating your thoughts to
others. It's just a means of
communication. But when a
person speaks, even when a
person thinks to himself, they
must make sure to match what
they say on the outside to what
they feel on the inside and
what they think. way a person
speaks should be the way a
person thinks. In the sense
that for instance, if a person
does not use profanity in his
each and a person should not
use profanity in his heart when
he's thinking and so on and so
forth.
We learn from these chapters
that words have meaning and
they have effects. Words are
very serious things. Words can
have profound effects on
listeners. And words can have a
profound effect even on the one
speaking himself. What does
that mean? scholars have
mentioned with regards to
for instance, the statement of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
speaks about the hypocrites.
And he describes them as
individuals who are deaf, dumb,
and blind. Deaf, they cannot
hear, dumb, they cannot speak,
blind, they cannot see. And
what's meant by this is a
spiritual sense. Ly of the
heart, deafness of the heart,
and dumbness of the heart Now,
why are these three grouped
together? Two of them are
taking in and one is kind of
going out. Two of them are
input and one is output. The
scholars have mentioned that
these are the three main paths
to the heart. The three main
paths to the heart. What you
hear, what you see, but also
what you say. Because the way a
person speaks, reflects what is
in the heart, and when a person
speaks, it reaffirms whatever
it is that is in their heart.
What does this mean? A person
tells a lie the more they
continue to tell this lie, the
more they start to believe it
themselves.
a person and lie and even lie
to himself if a person tells
lies enough, they will start to
believe their own lies. This is
a very interesting phenomena.
That if a person says something
that is untruthful, they know
it's untruthful but they
continue to say it and double
down on this lie. They will
start to believe this lie
themselves. An instance of this
is the statement of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Where he
says
the Can we after run? He says
subhanahu wa ta'ala
[Silence]
We will not go to the fire. We
will not be punished in hell
except for a few days. This is
what they've told themselves.
They have invented this belief
that no matter what they do,
essentially, they will only be
punished in the fire for a
while because they are the
chosen people of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. So, they
believe that, you know, we do
all these bad things but
anyways, even if we were to be
punished, it will only be for a
few days. Now, when they first
came up with this, obviously,
they understood that this was
not true. But they continued to
say it and doubled down on it
until it became, until it
became a belief of theirs, and
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
describes this belief and he
says,
we says and they were deceived
in their religion they were
deceived by the lies that they
used to tell, by their own
fabrications. So they fabricate
a lie, they propagate it, and
then they start to believe it
themselves. This is one of the
reasons, one of the reasons
that lying is so terrible in
Islam. And with Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. So words have a huge
effect. And a person should
always choose his words
carefully. Think about what he
is about to say before he says
it. Analyze it. And a person
should always choose proper
wordings. For instance, the
prophet says, the narration of
He says
he says whoever believes in
Allah in the last day, then
this person should speak with
that which is good or remain
silent. So, we have only one
option, only one kind of speech
that we can speak with and that
is that which is good in
itself. Otherwise, we must
remain quiet. We must remain
silent. We are not allowed to
speak unless we have something
good to say.
this means as Imam and Allah
has eluded to that this is that
a person must think about what
he is going to say before he
says it.
and if he realizes that this is
bad He should not say it. He's
not allowed to say it. If he
sees that this is neither good
nor bad, then he should not say
it. If he sees that he, if he
is unsure whether this is good
or bad, he is not allowed to
speak. A person is only allowed
to speak with that which he is
certain of being good or to
remain silent.
Let's take a let's take a look
and ponder the meaning here
that a person must speak with
that which is good or remain
silent. Now, notice how the
prophet worded this. He said,
speak with that which is good.
He didn't say speak with that
which is true. That which is
correct that which is good.
because not every truth is
necessarily appropriate to say.
That is not the only condition
of goodness that something be
true or factual in itself. As a
matter of fact, it may be a
major sin for a person to say
something that is true because
it's inappropriate. Now, for
example, what is backbiting?
Backbiting, Aliba, is when a
person says something true
about another person that is
disparaging, correct? That's
truth. saying something that
is factual. Yes, it is factual
but is it is inappropriate So,
it becomes a major sin to say
it. Maybe something is true but
inappropriate And perhaps
something is not necessarily
true but it is appropriate. A
person must speak with that
which is good or remain silent.
And so, we have three things to
look at when it comes to good,
that which is good speech.
Number one, we have to look at
the thing itself that we're
going to say. Is it in itself
good? Meaning, it's honest,
it's correct, it's truthful,
it's accurate. The second thing
we need to look at is, is it
appropriate Meaning, where I
say it or how I say it. Is it
appropriate? Number three, what
are the ramifications of this
statement? Right? A person may
say something that is true,
that is correct, it's maybe
unappropriate time to say it,
an appropriate place to say it,
but it's
maybe, maybe disastrous
person
who says something that
has a bad effect on people An
example of this is is teaching
are certain aspects of history
or certain aspects of the Quran
or Sunnah that are not
appropriate for the listener.
because not all knowledge is
appropriate for all people at
all times.
Does that make sense? Not all
knowledge is appropriate for
all people at all times. It may
even be a narration A a word
that was a statement of the
prophet but the listener is not
prepared for for that that
narration. They are not of a
certain level of knowledge to
be able to understand and
implement the narration
properly. An example of this is
that
was with the prophet and the
prophet said,
the
[Silence]
any partners unto him and the
right of the servants upon
Allah is that he will not
punish them if they do so.
Said, should I not inform
people of this? Should I not
announce this great news to the
people? He said, do not tell
them, lest they become
laxadaisical in their worship
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
They misunderstand these words.
They start to that, well, I
worship Allah. I don't
associate any partners unto
him. Therefore, I don't have to
work as hard in doing good
deeds. Now, what happens
instead of this making their
worship intensify, it actually
because of their level of
knowledge, it will, cause their
good deeds to lessen and cause
regress in their worship of
Allah. So, not all knowledge is
appropriate for all people
Who said
Speak to people on their level
with that which they can
understand and relate to.
So a person a scholar who is
well versed in the Quran and in
the is a skilled doctor.
He knows how to prescribe this
medicine. He knows which
narrations are appropriate for
which listeners. He knows what
aspects of knowledge are
appropriate for the listener.
It's not he's just opens up the
pharmacy and starts giving out
all the you know, all the
medications to everyone.
Certain medications might kill
people. Certain medications
might harm people right? So,
this is a very important aspect
of the way that we speak. We
have to be very careful with
the words that we choose and
things that we say and how we
say them.
to the point that we are to
take such care with the way
that we speak so as not to even
momentarily give the listener
the wrong image.
so as to not even momentarily
give the listener the wrong
image momentarily. What does
that mean? For instance,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala puts
his words in a particular order
so that when a person is
thinking and imagining in his
mind's eye what Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala is saying no image
will come through a person's
mind that is unintended.
not even momentarily For
instance, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says,
this is a good example here.
So, he says subhanahu wa
ta'ala, nothing is or
similar to Allah. and he is the
all hearing, the all seeing.
right? Look at the order of
this. First, we have negation
Nothing is Allah. Then, we
have affirmation. He affirms
for himself. Something that we
are familiar with, familiar
with its its basic concept and
that is and he is the all
hearing, all seeing. So, first,
we start with negation. If it
was the other way around
Allah is the all hearing, all
seeing, and nothing is like
unto him. There's a difference
now. Because for a moment, a
person may imagine that Allah's
sight is the sight of the
human being. That Allah's
hearing is the hearing of
a human being. but then, that
image is removed by his
statement. Nothing is unto
him but the image already
happened in the listener's
mind. It already flashed
through their mind. That
momentary flash of a
misconception will have a bad
effect on the person because
once a particular idea has
sparked itself in a person's
mind, it's very difficult to
remove that entirely. So Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala begins with
negation so that the listener
has no chance of
misunderstanding what the verse
means. So, he begins with,
nothing is Allah. That's
what we base everything on. All
of our things that we affirm
for Allah, his existence, his
life, his knowledge, his
hearing, his seeing, nothing is
them. But then he affirms
for himself and he is the all
all things. So, now, we have a
proper picture and that is that
is hearing is something that we
can't imagine. We don't know
[Arabic recitation]
His vision, we have no idea
what it's like. We know what
the concept of hearing is. We
know what the concept of vision
is but we have a principle that
precedes that and that is
nothing is Allah. Right?
Same thing. Even even in look
how it's structured.
So he begins with negation and
then has affirmation. Right?
The scholars say
a a Teskia
[Silence]
comes before ad orning
something. First, we clean and
purify something before we
adorn it, right? What does that
mean? That means that for
instance none is rightfully
worshiped. So, the mind is
completely emptied of all
things worshiped. Then, we have
affirmation. Except for Allah.
So, when the the concept of the
worship of Allah comes into the
heart, it comes into a heart
that's been purified and
cleansed of all other
misconceptions right This is a
principle followed in the Quran
and in the very carefully and
that is that purification
proceeds adornment,
beautification. So, for
instance, could you imagine if
somebody is dirty? They're
unclean. They haven't showered
in a week. If we go and take
cologne or perfume and spray
this person down with this
perfume
what's
going and then we put
new brand-new clothes on this
person What's going to happen
to the perfume and the
clothing? Obviously, it's
going to become, it's going to
become soiled and it's going to
become diluted with with the
filth that is still on the
person's body. So, now, the the
the perfume and the new
clothing has been ruined.
Right? Yeah. It's it's been
deluded with filth And then
after we put on perfume and
after we put on fresh clothes
then we go and take a shower.
What happens now? You cannot
completely rid yourself of the
of the the the the dirt, the
dirtiness that you had
previously. Rather a person
needs to clean himself first,
then, you beautify yourself or
you adorn yourself with perfume
and new clothing and so forth.
It's not the other way around.
So, you begin with cleaning,
then, you, then, you adorn and
and beautify. It can't be that
adorn and then try to clean
around that adornment because
you will you will end up with
neither completely. So, this is
very important that we
understand that something when
we say it, it has to be good in
itself Number two, it has to be
appropriate in the place, time,
and way that it's said. Number
three, it's effects need to be
appropriate. That when a person
says something, it has a
positive effect on the listener
in the proper order. If it has
a negative effect on the
listener, then, this is not
considered to be something good
right? This is now become
something that is bad because
it has negative effect or it's
bad because it was
inappropriate or it's bad
because it in itself is not
good. All of this begins with
what? The way a person speaks.
excuse me, the way a person
thinks Thoughts is the
beginning of all of this. and
this is this is actually a
question that comes up more
than you would more than you
would expect. Some people ask,
they say, how can I, what are
the steps I should take to
learn to better my speech and
not and not curse or not use
profanity. Person has a habit
of using profanity. How can
they clean their their speech
up? The answer is, do not with
profanity. The way that you
think when you are speaking to
yourself, don't use anything
that you wouldn't be
comfortable using out loud. And
this all goes back to the
statement of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. In about a he says
subhanahu wa ta'ala and Surat
he says, Stay away from most
insinuation or suspicion
because some suspicion is
sinful.
So, when
a person suspects or
is suspicious of another person
or thinks bad or ill of another
person, this in itself is
haram.
If it is unfounded So, all of
this begins with how a person
thinks There are few problems
with our modern speech. Our
modern speech, especially in in
our time and place here in
America, we have certain ways
of saying things and certain
ways of speaking that are
actually very negative and I'll
I'll mention some of these
things. Number one, the use,
the excessive use of profan
profane language to the point
that some people can't even
utter a sentence without it
being laced with two or three
or five. Words of profanity,
right? Cursing. This is not
only terrible in itself. But it
is also unintelligent. Person
who is profane and speaks with
profanity. This articulates a
person having a depraved way of
thought and that this person is
is unable to express himself
properly without using these
emphatic profanities.
and so, this is this is one
issue here. Now, again, it's
not just what you say but it's
how you say it. For instance,
I'll give you a good example
When I when a person speaks
What are they actually doing?
They're drawing a picture in
the mind of the listener,
right? This is what speech is.
You are drawing a picture in
the mind of the listener.
and so, When a person outright
says something profane It is
you know, reverberating in the
listener's mind. Likewise, when
a person insinuates something
that is profane, and it's kind
of interesting. For example, on
on television, right? They'll
have subtitles for instance and
a person will use profanity and
so in the subtitles, they will
take the first letter of the
profane word and they'll make
the rest, you know, an
exclamation mark and a question
mark and a# and right? You've
just done the same exact thing.
There's no difference between
just saying it outright or
insinuating it. The the
listener heard the same thing
in their mind. Am I making
sense? Do you understand what
I'm speaking about? So, for
instance, they'll have the
first letter of a profanity and
then they'll bleep out the
rest. It's the same thing and
he had either You've just
insinuated the profanity mind
of the listener So, this is
something that is very
widespread and it's very
unfortunate and it's something
that we have to work on and
make sure that we teach our
children as well. Another thing
is using vulgarity. Using
vulgar words. What is
vulgarity? Vulgarity is
inappropriate. Words. right?
the description of body
parts, the description of of
actions, the description. This
is something that is
inappropriate. A person should
not allow his children for
instance to use this kind of
blunt language. blunt language
in this fashion is not good. It
is unhealthy
Another Another issue that we
have is using emphasis
inappropriately.
What does that mean using
emphasis inappropriately? Pay
attention to
this point here Using emphasis
inappropriately will end up
blunting the language. So, for
example, a person has something
that taste good to him. Now,
they start to use emphatic,
hyperbolus language This was
the best tasting thing I've
ever had in my life. It was so
wonderfully great. Now, what
happens if you have something
that tastes better? How are you
going to describe that? Right?
I am so tired. I'm dead tired.
What happens when you really
are dead tired? How do you
describe that now? Do you
understand what I mean? This
blunts the language. It blunts
it. It takes words of emphasis
that are are used for emphasis
and now it makes them just
regular, mediocre
and this is usually why
profanity comes into speech
because it starts being used to
make up for the lack of
emphasis found in our normal,
in our normal speech, in our
normal expressions of emphasis.
person has, you know, kind of a
slum date. This was the worst
day of my life This day was
terrible. It was horrendous. I
was appalled about something
that is my new show or
something that is trivial. This
blunts a person's language.
Another thing that is common
that blunts language is using
things as a form of politeness
using them or saying them too
much. What makes a diamond
valuable What makes a diamond
valuable? Diamond for instance
or platinum or these things
that are considered valuable.
What makes them valuable?
Huh? Rarity. Rarity. Rarity
makes them valuable, correct?
Yeah. A diamond is is valuable
because it's rare. If it,
that's why pebbles or stones
aren't valuable because they're
everywhere. If stones were rare
and diamonds were all over the
place, then diamonds would not
be valuable. Stones would be
valuable. So, rarity and
scarcity is what makes these
things valuable. Likewise are
things the word sorry. You
notice how in common culture,
how sorry is used? Every,
sorry. Oh, I apologize. Oh, my
bad. I'm sorry, sorry, sorry.
So, now, when you really
want to say sorry, it means
nothing. Has no meaning. This
blunts the language.
It makes language ineffective
A person should not use words
this, sorry. you are
wonderful, you're great, you're
awesome. All these kind of
hyperboles things that are
overly emphatic. This will work
towards blunting the language
and making it weaker. so that
when you actually say sorry for
something that deserves sorry,
it is, it is no longer
valuable. It means nothing.
This person's always saying
sorry. You bump him to him,
they say sorry, you know,
you shoot them or they shoot
you, they say sorry. Sorry is
is this equal. So, this is,
these are some things that are
very important when it comes to
speech. Another aspect of the
sunnah that Ibnnu Kaim speaks
about here. is the issue of
using words
and applying them to something
that is inappropriate right?
Using words, applying them to
something that is inappropriate
So, first, we discussed using
emphasis where emphasis is not
deserved. Second of all, using
words where the words are not
deserved. So, for instance,
gives us an example here and
the
he he prohibited that a
hypocrite or a person that is a
bad person be referred to as a
you know, someone who is of
nobility, you would not use
this language for someone who
is not deserving of it. and
this is something that's really
widespread
This happens a lot in circles
of, you know, with and people
that speak, you know, like
imams of the Masjid or we use
these big names and these big
titles we give them. This is
Alem. Right? Alema means a man
is an ocean of knowledge. What
happens when we really meet
Alema? What are we going to
call him? right? Likewise, if
we call the hypocrites Sayed
and we call the believers say
it, what does say it now mean?
It means nothing. It has no
meaning.
So, in order to maintain the
sharpness of these words, we
make sure that we apply them
properly. We refer to a
scholar, as a scholar, we refer
to a Khabib as a Khabib. We
refer to, you know, look at the
word Sheikh. Does Sheikh mean
anything anymore? And in our
language here, just in general.
The word Sheikh, does it mean
anything? a young man could be
17, 18 years old, recites the
Quran nicely. All of a sudden,
he's Sheikh Chalas. So, the
word Sheikh means nothing
anymore. It has no meaning
because we use it on everybody
right? even the word scholar.
It really doesn't mean anything
anymore. Or half of a half of
before Three, 400 years ago
from the beginning of Islam
till about 200 years ago. The
word half of is used to refer
to someone who has memorized at
least 100, 000 narrations. If a
person has not memorized at
least 100, 000 narrations, they
are not a half of. What does
half of me now? Not really
much. or person, you know,
memorizes the Quran.
that the word half of doesn't
even have that much of a a
meaning anymore because we've
overused it. It's no longer
rare But when we overuse
something, it's value drops,
right? Just if tomorrow,
all of the people in the world
brought all of the US dollars
that they have, brought it all
back to America, and dumped it
into America. What would happen
to the US dollar? US dollar
would become abundant. Everyone
has it and now it no longer has
any value. and this is what
happens when we have things
inflation, right? We're
just printing money, printing,
money, printing, money. Now,
money means nothing. So, now,
we have to raise the price.
Instead of a dollar, now it's
20 because a dollar has no
meaning on its own anymore.
These are important aspects of
using speech properly. These
are things that the prophet has
taught us on how to speak. If
we look at especially the newer
generations, I honestly feel
very afraid for the newer
generations because the level
of eloquence and intelligence
in speeches plummeted. In
recent years. because there is
a lack of yeah, I mean, the
younger generation has a very
difficult time articulating
themselves properly.
and
do you notice for instance,
the use of the word I
wanted to you know, like,
do this thing and it's like,
you know, I like,
that's what the
whole sentence is structured
about and profanity. This
articulates what? A lack of
intelligence. Because the way
that you speak, articulates
what your mind, how your mind
is structured.
This is why
illiteracy is very very serious
thing. If a person is
illiterate in this time, in
this age, that articulates a
lack of structure to a person's
thought. The way that you
structure your thoughts and the
way that you organize your
thoughts, this comes from
reading a lot. When a person is
able to read and they are able
to read books, the more they
read, and the level of the
books that they read and the
language that they read. This
will translate to the way that
they think and this is not just
my claims. These aren't just my
claims. This is this is
something that has been studied
recently For instance,
we we usually look at
presidential debates in
research as kind of a measuring
stick of of the level of
intelligence of the general
public.
So,
compared to the Trump era, the
Obama era, those presidential
debates were very
sophisticated, correct? Obama
era, the two thousand and
eight, two thousand and 14
presidential debates, our 2012
presidential debate, we're at a
sixth grade level. 6th grade,
That is extremely low because
anything more intelligent than
that, most of the population is
not going to understand what's
being said. So, even though
people are becoming more
literate, the type of
literature that they are
reading is causing huge
plummets and regression and
human thoughts. So, we will
continue this narrative next
[Arabic recitation]